let's take a quick look at the axioms of
Zermelo Fraenkel set theory with choice
so the axioms of ZFC
define the standard theory of sets which
is now accepted by most most
mathematicians as a reliable and simple
basis for developing and justifying all
of mathematics among the axioms may be a
simple one to understand and really the
motivation for this short video is
twofold one is practice with writing
predicate formulas and the other is to
think a little bit more about self
application so one of the basic axioms
of set theory is called extensionality
which is capturing the idea that a set
is determined by its members so let's
consider the assertion that two sets X
and y have the same elements which we
could write as a predicate formula in
set theory as for all X X is a member of
Y if and only if X is a member of Z now
we've could use this as a definition of
equality it's what we mean by y&z are
equal but we don't really need to even
introduce equality as a basic part of
the language and and axioms about how it
behaves there's one axiom that covers
things adequately and that is that if
two sets have the same members then they
are members of the same sets so if well
the members of x and y are the same then
x and y are members of exactly the same
things which we can say this way for
every X Y is in X if and only if Z is in
X so that is one of the basic axioms of
sex theory maybe the start with a
starting one another one is the power
set axiom which simply says that every
set has a power set how would you say
that in the language of predicate set
theory well you'd say that for every X
there is a P which is going to be the
power set of X such that for every set s
s is a subset of X if and only if s is a
member of pay remember we know how to
express as
a subset of X in the language of
predicate calculus mentioning only
membership so this is a good axiom that
says yes there is a set P consisting of
precisely the subsets of X that set P is
called the power set of X when you're
trying to deal with the Russell's
paradox kind of issue where you define a
set of elements or as a collection of
sets that satisfy some property the the
safe conservative version of saying that
that a set of elements that satisfy some
property really is a set of collection
of elements that satisfy some property
really is a say on the comprehension
axiom is a simple version of an axiom
that allows you to do that so basically
it says that if s is a set and P of X is
an arbitrary a predicate of set theory
which might in fact be one of these
dangerous things like X is not a member
of X nevertheless if you look at those
elements in the set s that satisfy P of
X that's a set in other words the set of
X in s such that P of X is a set it
means that any definable collection of
elements within a set also form a proper
subset and the reason why this matters
is remember if I just talked about not
the set of X in a particular set s that
satisfy P of X if I just talked about
the collection of X's that satisfy P of
X that's when I start getting into
Russell's paradox areas when I declare
that the set of X such that P of X is a
set for unrestricted P of X but all I
need to do is put a bound on me on the
elements that X ranges over the X is a
member of some particular set then it's
safe to take all of those X's that
satisfy P of X now another particularly
interesting axiom of ZF which addresses
this issue of self app of self
membership and self reference is that
the intuitive idea that the elements of
a set have to come before this
it sells they have to be simpler than
the sin of self than the set itself if
you think about sort of building up a
set from successively simpler elements
to more complicated ones in particular
um you can't have a set be a member of
itself because then it's not being built
from things that are simpler than it is
or booboo or that came before it is in
fact you can't even have a set that's a
member of a member of itself all of that
kind of of indirect membership is
forbidden now how do you say that isn't
nice axiom well there's a very elegant
way to do it and that is to say that all
sets are well founded under membership
which means that you can't find an
infinite sequence of sets where each one
has the preview has the next one as a
member
let's give a precise way to formulate
that it's also good practice with the
formulas of set theory let me say that X
is membership minimal Epsilon minimal in
Y means that X is a member of Y but
there's no element of X that's also in Y
in other words X is built out of things
that are not in Y but X itself is in Y
so X kind of comes before any of the
other elements in Y it's built out of
non Y stuff so to say this with a
formula when you just say that X is in Y
and for every Z if it's in X then it's
not in Y so that's the definition that X
is membership minimal in Y and then the
basic axiom of ZF called the foundation
axiom simply says that every non-empty
set has a membership minimal element
this is actually kind of generalization
of the well ordering principle that says
that every non-empty set of non-negative
integers has a least element this is a
direct analogy just as the the well
ordering principle for integers implies
that you can't have an infinite
decreasing sequence of non-negative
integers the foundation axiom actually
implies that you can have an infinite
sequence of sets each of which is a
member of the previous one
and here is a formula that's asserting
foundation for every X if X is not empty
that implies that there is a Y such that
Y is membership minimal in X well what
is that the foundation got to do with
membership well the foundation will
actually will very quickly let us
conclude that no set is a member of
itself how does that work well suppose
that um you are interested in some set
and you like to verify that this set
can't be a member of itself well let R
be the set consisting of just this set s
that you're interested in R is the
singleton s it's only element than s
well R is not empty and by the
foundation axiom it must have a
membership minimal element now suppose
that s is an S we're going to reach a
contradiction the claim is that R has no
membership minimal element and that
violates the foundation axiom so you
can't have s as a member of s why does
this follow well look R is supposed to
have a membership minimal element
well ours only got one element so if
it's got any membership element it's got
to be s but s can't be membership
minimal because s is in R and it's got
and and which means that S has an
element in R in it so s is not our
minimal and the foundation axiom then
immediately implies that you can't have
s be a member s s is not minimal
membership minimal in R and this
argument extends in a in a nice way to
member of a member a member of a member
and we'll throw a feedback on one
question about that at you shortly so
looking at the foundation axiom in the
conclusion that no set is a member of
itself what we can immediately conclude
is that first of all the collection of
all sets can't be a set because if all
sets if the collection of all sets was a
set then it would be a member of itself
that's forbidden by the S can't be a
member of S consequence in the
foundation axiom the second thing it
tells us is remain
the set W from Russell's paradox W was
the collection of those sets which are
not members of themselves well now we've
just figured out that this is all sets
because no set is a member of itself so
the sets that are not members of
themselves is everything and that's why
W is not a set and not a member of
itself which explains finally how the
foundation axiom resolves of the Russell
paradox